[Applause]
hi I'm Stuart Brandt from the long now
foundation Frank Gavin comes for me from
a conference that I went to that
pyramidal Pierre Omidyar helped fund and
they had a longer term for it but it was
basically applied history how can
history be used better decision-making
how has it been used badly and
decision-making in the past historians
were very good at sorting that out if
all goes well I would love to see what
Frank is talking about tonight become a
sub-discipline within history and within
Foreign Affairs and Kennedy school type
stuff become part of how people think
about government how they think about
strategy making in large organizations
including corporations and if that
discipline comes to happen you will have
seen the very first page of it tonight
Frank Kevin
[Applause]
well thank you Seward for that very kind
introduction that's not too much to have
to live up to now creating a whole new
discipline but I appreciate that first
let me say what an honor it is to be
here and to point out this is a somewhat
unusual venue for me not because this
wonderful setting or this diverse
audience is something that I don't like
but because of what I gather is the
thrust of what these talks are about
predicting or anticipating the future
this is not something historians
typically do and it's fact there's some
skepticism about the whole notion of
forecasting we can't agree what happened
in the past that's what we spend our
time doing fighting over what actually
did happen and we can't agree so you can
imagine how much skepticism we have
about trying to think what is going to
happen in the future I'll just give you
one example from my own work I do a lot
of work on nuclear politics and nuclear
proliferation and one of the most
striking things about this field is
alarmist predictions of disaster pretty
much every year throughout the whole
period of the nuclear age there has been
someone important predicting disaster
was going to happen in the most sort of
famous example that I wrestled with all
the time as President Kennedy gave a
speech saying that by the 1970s there
would be 20 or 30 nuclear powers in the
world and it never happened there have
been similar predictions about nuclear
terrorist events happening people like
Graham Allison and Bob Gallucci making
these predictions and they don't happen
and these predictions simply haven't
come true and in fact the opposite has
happened we have far fewer nuclear
weapons programs around the world than
we had 30 years ago and I would argue
these poor predictions have fed into
some pretty terrible policies throughout
the world over the years so one might
consider me a skeptic and wonder what
I'm doing here
just because a historical sensibility
makes you cautious about predicting and
forecasting does not mean
it cannot help you think about and even
prepare for the future and that is why
I'm here now what are the benefits if
any to applying in a very rigorous
manner historical knowledge e knowledge
and methodology to the making of u.s.
foreign policy are their advantage for
policymakers and thinking about the past
in a serious way and should historians
consider these decision-makers as part
of their audience now for an audience
like this I would assume that the answer
would be of course that's just a common
sense sort of response that a deep
understanding of the past
can only benefit us as we think about
making important decisions in the future
yet I'm here to tell you that
policymakers rarely call upon historians
for insight perhaps even more surprising
however is that there are a few serious
attempts by what might be called
scholarly historians trained and
employed by our most important research
universities in this country to write
for a policy audience nor is it common
for policymakers to access their work
now there are exceptions here I have
some pictures of the books that actually
were the exceptions in this and there's
two really leading figures who tried to
change this and to be honest with you
who have failed Paul Kennedy is one and
the most important is a great historian
who just passed away this year
earnest May who spent much of his career
trying to change this attitude both in
Washington and in the ivory tower and
for the most part had very little
success now I could go into great detail
about the current state of historical
the historical profession and why Ernie
May failed and why the attempt to get
historians and policymakers engaged each
other has come to nothing that talk
would depress you the situation is bleak
there's this third quote here I mean the
first two quotes I have are essentially
about why it is you would want to have
history and why you would want
historical knowledge as opposed to
things like law or economics or a
national relations theory about why as
the most important military power in the
world having some knowledge of your past
is absolutely critical to making good
decisions
the last quote probably says more about
the field the profession I find myself
in than just about any and it came from
my Jill Lepore a quote the American
historical profession defines itself by
its dedication to the proposition that
looking to the Past to explain the
present falls outside of the realm of
serious historical study now think about
that
I sort of people who are not familiar
with how the historical community works
I'm sure this is shocking what this
means is that no self-respecting
historian would ever think of using his
or her knowledge to advise policymakers
such an effort would simply be dismissed
as not serious something that we just
wouldn't do now what explains this
situation there are at least three
important reasons why historians and
policy makers don't have a more fruitful
relationship and I should say these are
legitimate reasons these are important
reasons first policy makers are not
interested in the past for its own sake
policy makers are forced to make
extraordinarily difficult choices under
enormous time pressures and government
officials understandably want usable
knowledge that provides guidance for
making the best decisions understandably
they seek certainty particularly about
the future and they're grateful for
clear-cut rules and parsimonious or
simple explanations that's not what we
do that's not what his stories do we
don't do anything simple we don't do
anything parsimonious and we certainly
don't like rules
historians don't like to generalize over
space and time and the comparative
advantage of history is is is in
exposing complexity nuance in shades of
gray studying the past discourage his
efforts to simplify or forecast and I
should point out that the two historians
who are were the leading advocates of
the kind of thing I'm talking about
Ernest Mae and Paul Kennedy in their
efforts to make predictions did a really
bad job of it we all know Paul Kennedy
talked about in the late 1980s that
Japan would be a superpower and leaving
the United States behind Ernest made
earnest May made predictions in the
1970s that the Cold War was gonna calm
down and there would be no more
militarization this is right before
Ronald Reagan was elected so there
aren't a lot of really good examples of
historians predicting the future and it
doesn't give one a lot of confidence
unlike economics international relations
theory which aim for parsimony
generalization and prediction historical
scholarship often appears to offer
little that can be of immediate help to
a policymaker a second reason for the
poor relationship is the deep suspicion
that historians have a power and people
who wield it scholars warn that
historical works should not be used to
validate broader political claims and
this is an important argument if such a
political effort is to be made it should
be made on behalf of groups and issues
that have been ignored or
underrepresented not on behalf of policy
elites they've had the benefit of
everything working out in history
historians if they're engaged in the
process of advocating anything it
shouldn't be on behalf of policy elites
furthermore national history has a less
than stellar record in many parts of the
world including at times the United
States as the past has often been
exploited to justify morally problematic
policies the record of scholars who have
been in positions of power in the United
States or have been close to power has
not always been exemplary and this is
something that always needs watching
finally the third reason for the fact
that this relationship is not better is
that it's important to remember the
policy is only a very small part of the
past which historians seek to explain
even scholars like myself who focus on
international history or American
foreign relations are as likely to
emphasize factors outside of the realm
of policy as those in policy we may
focus on structural factors like
geography long-term trends such as
demographic or economic shifts or
cultural or intellectual véra
variables like the changing role of race
and gender gender or the emergence of
new ideas when we explain why certain
things happen and why things happen the
way they do in the international
environment
these aren't policy issues or their if
they're policy issues there are only
policy issues at a very removed place
now all of these are very powerful
reasons for historians to look for
different audiences and for policy
makers to seek wisdom and guidance
elsewhere the requirements for good
historical scholarship are certainly are
rarely in line with the needs of
decision-makers in government so what's
my conclusion then does that mean that
it's a bad idea for historians to write
for policy makers and for policy makers
have taken interest in historical
methodology should the history professor
stay locked in their ivory towers
keeping their knowledge to themselves
far away from the corrupting influences
of power in our nation's capital or
should history and policy mix is history
actually good for you I wouldn't be here
if I didn't think the answer was yes the
issues policymakers confront are too
important and the benefit of historical
insight too great for them to avoid
communicating with each other developing
a historical sensibility can do much to
improve policymakers understanding of
the world they find themselves in and
depending on how the knowledge is used
improve the quality of policy now there
are advantages for the historian as well
while scholars may want to maintain a
healthy distance from the political
process it does not mean that their
historical work should be obscure filled
with jargon or irrelevant to the
concerns of policymakers and if you want
to actually see what most historical
scholarship looks like look at some of
the leading journals and that is exactly
what you'll see jargon irrelevance and a
lot of obscurity nor is there anything
wrong with scholarship being useful and
it's fair to say that much of the
professional historical field has for
any number of reasons embraced
methodologies and studied subjects that
are far afield from the concerns or
interests of a marked much larger public
to say nothing of the policy community
and now well some of this cutting-edge
work is to be admired
there's
danger that this scholarship is
meaningful to smaller and smaller
audiences exploding my own work on u.s.
foreign strategic and economic policy
during the 1950's 60s and 70s I would
like to lay out five key concepts which
have properly understood and employed
should provide a firmer grasp on how
historical analysis can be a benefit to
policymakers and not just the
policymakers but to an informed public
at large these concepts are vertical
history horizontal history chronological
proportionality unintended consequences
and policy and significance now I should
note none of these five concepts are
particularly novel or profound in fact
one of the advantages of possessing
knowledge of the past and if in the
familiarity with historical methodology
is a healthy skepticism of claims of
profoundness originality and either the
world in any of the world of events or
policy responses nor is it necessary to
accept my historical interpretations and
I'm going to give you tonight to
recognize the value of these concepts
I'm going to lay out what I think
happened in the past and what I believe
it means you can and should disagree
with that while still accepting that the
very process of wrestling with these
interpretations can be extraordinarily
beneficial in fact developing historical
sensibility should encourage all of us
to challenge the received wisdom about
the past and current US policies and
encourage not just policymakers but the
public at large to develop their own
explanations the first concept is
vertical history what do I mean by
vertical history this is actually the
simplest most straightforward and the
one that most people are familiar with
when looking at any historical event or
phenomena a historian should first look
at its temporal origins its origins and
time and its spatial location and depth
temporal origins and chronology might be
thought of as vertical history again
this is the easiest concept sort of an A
to B to C to D causality
it's sequential it involves common-sense
notions of causality and agency and it's
essentially the story of how events have
fold over time but it's deserve some
further explore exploration while
exploring events and explaining events
over time would seem to be
straightforward is never a simple or
uncontested process as anyone who has
studied controversial issues such as the
causes of the first world war
understands identifying cause as an
agent's depends upon the perspective of
the historian including spatially
culturally and temporally causes can be
either proximate or long-term despite
these difficulties however sophisticated
historical analysis is useful in both
revealing the deeper origins of
important events and exposing when the
origins and causality are less clear
than people may think it's important to
note that this kind of vertical history
is less to do with the case study method
that you might see in business school or
among political scientists or process
tracing and instead seeks to identify
deeper more complex and often surprising
chronological routes for a particular
policy situation one thing anyone in my
field does all the time is Russell with
the origins of the first world war and
this is something if you follow this
debate you would think at this point
after thousands and thousands of books
and articles having been written about
this that we'd actually know what the
answer is but you see in this process of
how scholars and historians wrestle with
this you can see how important
understanding vertical vertical history
is and it's often a balance on the one
hand you have the proximate causes the
July crisis diplomatic dispatches
military timetables the kind of
intensity and pressure of what we know
to be sort of the guns of August and the
crisis of July and that's balanced out
with longer-term issues demographic
trends like the increasing pressure of
population in Europe produced by
industrialization urbanization at the
turn of the century the influence of
economic competition and particularly
imperialism which had been dealt
developing over a century and a half and
the rising an extraordinarily powerful
force of national
so you have these long-term course
causes in these short-term causes and
trying to wrestle and understand them is
a very important skill to develop a good
vertical history can also reveal when a
seemingly small change when within a
complex system can produce profound
changes to an international environment
over time and I'm going to give you an
example of this an example of how
vertical history might be used to lift
the veil to reveal the deeper less known
sources of the world policymakers face
would be to reconstruct the long-term
roots or causes of current US policy and
what might be termed the greater Middle
East this is obviously the most
important region that we worry about in
our current policy environment when and
for what reasons did this region become
such an important focus of US policy and
how did American interests develop here
what are the causes of the United States
close relationship with such problematic
allies such as Saudi Arabian Israel and
its bitter enmity with Iran these are
very important questions and I would
think if you were in policy today you
would want to know the answers to them
well a contemporary analysis that
focused on proximate causes might
identify a variety of factors ones that
you're all familiar with and you might
agree with the importance of oil the
American economy right that's something
that certainly has motivated things the
threat of terrorism certainly since 9/11
and instability in the region concerns
about nuclear proliferation and powerful
domestic support for Israel within the
United States
now these interests it's widely assumed
have driven US policy for some time and
our policies in the region at least it
is believed have been pretty much
constant since the middle of the 20th
century doing historical detailed
historical work assessing the
longer-term consequences might provide a
more nuanced picture
consider the following interpretation
based on historical analysis of a series
of relatively minor events that have
profound long-term consequences for US
policy in the Middle East now few people
know this but until the mid-1960s the
Middle East was not an area of primary
geopolitical or strategic
for the United States falling far behind
Europe in East Asian even at times
behind Latin America as an area that the
United States considered a geopolitical
priority it was Great Britain not the
United States who in the Western
alliance had primary responsibility for
ensuring the security and stability of
the region energy was not a first order
issue we had more than enough oil up
until the middle of the 1960s and
regional rivalries and conflicts between
Saudi Arabia and Egypt or Syria and Iraq
were of little concern to us
policymakers perhaps even most
surprising Israel was not even
considered a particularly close ally in
1965 the United States sold more weapons
to Jordan than it did to Israel
now how and why did this situation
change the key to understanding the
evolving role of the Middle East during
the is to understand it within the
context of the Cold War rivalry between
the Soviet Union in the United States
and a series of events that seemed small
at the time but unfolded in ways that
had a profound influence on the history
of the region a historian reconstructing
the story might argue that starting the
late 1950s but increasing in scope in
the 1960s the Soviets began to target
the greater Middle East as a region
where they could make geopolitical
inroads Western Europe was largely
secure East Asia was becoming
increasingly a place of US dominance but
the Middle East appeared to be a place
where the Soviet Union could actually
have some influence and under Khrushchev
and continued by successors this became
a primary focus of policy starting with
Nasser's Egypt and moving to Iraq and
Syria Russia used vigorous diplomacy in
generous a to gain friends in the region
this effort caught the United States
flat-footed and when tensions between
Israel and its Arab neighbors sparked a
war in 1967 the Johnson administration
was for the most part caught completely
off guard the United States was even
less prepared for the consequences of
the war now recent historical work and
looking in the archives has made it
clear that Egypt and Syria's
aggressiveness in the middle 1960
was in no small part driven by Soviet
support and prodding reflecting Russia's
desire to gain greater influence in the
region now this is all well and good but
how did this end up changing US policy
in the region well the war in 1967
created a financial crisis that
exasperated an already desperate British
balance attainments the payment payments
deficit that led in November of 1967 to
a devaluation of sterling more ominously
as a result of this devaluation Great
Britain announced its intent to
withdrawal its military commitment to
the region
so this war created pressure on British
currency in order to sort of relieve
some of this pressure the British said
we're no longer going to support it
militarily and that left a serious
dilemma the conundrum for US policy
makers the United States found itself
obviously in 1967 in a very poor
geopolitical position in the region the
Soviets were moving aggressively to
establish strategic dominance in the
region at the same time that its close
ally Great Britain was pulling out why
not enter and replace Great Britain why
not sort of simply become the strategic
guarantee of stability in the region
well it was 1967 and something else was
going on and that was the Vietnam War
and it was inconceivable that the United
States in 1967 could muster either the
military capability or more importantly
the political will to do what it took to
actually go in the Middle East to
replace Great Britain and the United
States was suffering its own
international monetary and financial
problems as well on the other hand the
United States was not willing to cede
the region so couldn't go in on its own
it didn't want to cede the region it
faced this geopolitical challenge what
did it do well came up with what has
become known first in the Johnson
administration and then the Nixon
administration as a pillar strategy
providing massive military and political
support to whatever Ally they could find
in the region that was willing to
support their aims and there were three
in particular Saudi Arabia Israel and
Iran
in the years following the six-day war
each of these three countries were given
or sold billions of dollars of the most
cutting-edge military equipment and our
political relationship with each of the
three changed dramatically this is as a
side note something that's very
interesting to look at in terms of our
relationship with Iran the United States
there's this kind of story this
narrative is it's especially popular in
Iran that the United States intervenes
overthrows the most attacked government
in the early 1950s and there's a
straight continuous line to the
revolution of 78 and 79 and we were bad
the whole way throughout
in fact we knew the Shah was a bad guy
and in the late 50s and early 60s we
would have had no problem whatsoever if
he disappeared from the scene and in
fact in 1963 it becomes very close to
the Shah being deposed we wouldn't have
done a thing to stop it we also had the
same ambivalence about the House of Saud
in Israel but after 1967 because of the
strategic necessity to have allies in
the region our relationship completely
changed and this is what I would argue
produced the consequences for US policy
that persisted well beyond the Cold War
I should note that this was a relatively
successful strategy the Soviets even
though Iran ended up turning against us
they didn't go in the Soviet camp Soviet
influence in the Middle East
actually waned and decreased and it was
a relatively successful policy yet the
consequences of it live with us
to this very day now this is of course
only one plausible interpretation of US
policy in the Middle East and the point
here is not to argue that it is correct
but to reveal how much nuance and depth
could provide how thinking historically
could provide the nuance and depth
necessary to have greater insight into
the policy environment u.s. policy
makers face today how many people do you
think making policy on the Middle East
have even the most basic understanding
of the story that I just told yet even
if you disagree with my interpretation
clearly it is something that has to be
wrestled with and understood this kind
of history also real reveals that
factors that seem small in this case the
British and American balance of payments
deficit can have larger and
longer-term consequences in the policy
environment a policymaker or a historian
for that matter would not have to accept
an interpretation based on the
centrality the 1967 war to explain US
policy in the greater Middle East today
in the same way one wouldn't either need
believe the first world war was caused
by long-term demographic pressures the
effects of European mobile imperialism
or Germans mobilization schedules in
August 1914 but it's the very act of
wrestling with these interpretations
understanding these different
perspectives trying to make sense of
them that actually provides the deeper
context to contemporary events and
reveals the complexity under the surface
of the most important global policy
issues we face today
now the second concept is one I call
horizontal history an understanding of
the past doesn't just relate to how
things evolved over time
it's also how they relate over space
history can expose horizontal
connections over space and in depth that
no one would have ever known
in other words good historical work can
move side to side not just front to back
or laterally and can reveal linkages
between issues that are not readily
apparent at first glance this is the
horizontal or spatial depth axis on a
historians imaginary graph again I'm
going to give another sort of obscure
somewhat boring historical example
though to show how all these things are
actually linked up in a sort of more
exciting way consider American foreign
policy in the 1960s and look again at
the obscure issue of international
monetary financial relations and
particularly this u.s. balance of
payments deficit now for a variety of
reasons including the somewhat
inefficient and contradictory rules of
the Bretton Woods international monetary
system the United States began
hemorrhaging dollars and losing its gold
supply in the 1960s and surplus
countries were using these surplus
dollars to buy gold during the later
years of the Eisenhower Kennedy and
Johnson administration and this was seen
as a grave economic threat in fact most
economists at the time in a way we
forget
thought if this was not handled
correctly that you could have a repeat
of the 1930s and the sort of global
deflation that brought about the
depression and also led to international
confirmation now there was a lot of
misunderstanding of how international
economics worked and that's always a
challenge for a historian what do you do
when people believe things that aren't
actually true or probably won't happen
but from a historical perspective what
was important is someone like President
Kennedy was absolutely obsessed with
this issue he was convinced that if
there was a run on gold he would be
forced to do things that could lead to
really grave consequences both for the
national economy and the International
economy and he wanted to avoid this at
all cost so right in the middle pretty
mundane fairly boring issue the balance
of payments deficit now both
administration's sought and this dollar
and gold train without resorting to
restriction is economic policies such as
interest rate hikes trade barriers and
capital controls your normal response
when you have this gotten a fixed
exchange rate system when you're losing
when your currencies and deficit is to
do some really unpleasant things that
shrink your own economy you hike
interest rates capital controls trade
restrictions no president wants to do
those kind of things so Kennedy
Eisenhower Johnson they all sought
policies that would somehow solve this
problem without actually following the
restrictive policies that could hurt the
economy and guarantee that they didn't
get elected again so both so all three
of these administration's focused on a
particularly expensive part of US
expenses abroad and that was the cost of
US troops and their families living
abroad the largest part of the balance
of payments deficit was the cost of
three hundred thousand US troops living
in Germany with their families and it
just so happened that the largest
surplus country the country that had
those dollars and was turning them in
for gold happened to be West Germany so
for understandable reasons policymakers
began to focus on this particular count
and focus on what could they do to
reduce the balance of payments costs of
troops
in western Germany in Western Europe but
there were a series of problems with
doing this at a time when nuclear parity
with the Soviets was right around the
corner people were worried and the West
Germans made it very clear they were
worried about this that plans the pull
us troops out of Europe could undermine
the credibility of the US commitment
defend Western Europe against the
Soviets and one had to worry how would
the Soviets interpret this would they
would this affect what effect with this
clash over economic and security issues
have on the cohesion of the Western
alliance the issue was even more complex
when the issue of nuclear policies were
taken to account Europeans on both sides
of the Iron Curtain agreed on only one
thing during the 1960s and that was that
the West Germans could never be allowed
to have access to atomic weapons yet
since the 1950s the West Germans had
expressed great interest in having
atomic weapons and this was the primary
cause of the conflict between the
Soviets and Americans in the 1950s in
the 1960s so how does this relate to the
balance of payments if the US was
pulling troops out of Western Europe and
if the West Germans felt increasingly
insecure and didn't believe that the
Americans would come to their defense
then they would start to wonder can we
trust the Americans should we defend
ourselves we're facing this enormous
enemy that has nuclear weapons maybe we
should have nuclear weapons of our own
and in fact one of the threats the West
Germans keep making is they say you keep
pulling troops out and it's going to be
very hard for us not to do things that
are going to lead us down the road of
having our own nuclear weapons now as
you can see all these things end up
linking together and in the end a series
of complex and hard-fought deals were
worked out that reassured West Germany
while keeping it non-nuclear protecting
the dollar and lessening the outflow of
US gold and in fact it is this very deal
that leads to the nuclear
non-proliferation treaty right if you go
to any sort of policy maker and say
where does the non-proliferation treaty
come from I guarantee you none of them
will say well it had something to do
with
to payments deficit the 1960s right but
you can see that there's this direct
connection between concerns over
International Monetary relations doing
something about the balance of payments
to the security of the Western alliance
to German nuclearization and this whole
series of policies are constructed to
deal with all these issues which end up
manifesting itself in the
non-proliferation agreement of 1968
now many analysts international
political economists nuclear strategists
experts in Germany trade experts have
looked at each of these particular
issues in isolation a trade personal
look at the trade affects an
international monetary personal look at
the monetary stuff a German expert a
look at Germany a nuclear person will
look at the nuclear issues very rarely
are these brought together and that's
what historians do historians make those
horizontal linkages good horizontal work
can reveal the complex interconnections
and trade-offs that permeate the most
important foreign policies this
bird's-eye view actually provides a more
holistic view of how policymaking
actually works this is how policymaking
works right the higher you go on the
policymaking process it's rare that you
just get to deal with one issue and not
think about its consequences I remember
having this insight when listening to
the presidential tapes that I worked on
years ago at the Miller center and you
would listen President Kennedy would
have a meeting at 9:00 a.m. on the
balance of payments 10:00 a.m. on the
tax cut 11:00 a.m. on Berlin 12:00 noon
on the comprehensive test-ban treaty and
so on and so forth now he was the only
guy in all those meetings he understood
all those linkages every time a new
group of experts would come in and a
whole bunch of other ones would leave
but one of the things that was clear was
the guy at the top understood that all
these things were deeply interconnected
and in order to make better policy more
effective policy understanding how those
connections work and understanding that
those exists are incredibly important
think about our current policy towards
say Pakistan Today or China's current
account surplus then a lot of people
probably have concerns about that I
guarantee you I don't know what they are
but you can do the same chart for each
of those issues and there's all sorts of
issues in connection
that you never would have thought of
that bear on the question that you're
looking at and all of these policies are
can be better understood through a lens
that includes horizontal historical
analysis the third concept is one I call
chronological proportionality and here
the question is very simple how do we
assess the long-term consequences and
effects of a current policy question you
pick up your newspaper you pick up the
New York Times and there's 10 or 15
articles you read what are the ones that
really matter what are the issues that
you're reading in the newspaper they're
actually going to be of any consequence
20 or 30 years from now that's actually
a very hard thing to do and this is what
the whole skill the notion of
chronological proportionality sets out
to try to achieve there's all sorts of
issues there's many issues that seem
like a very big deal when they happen
and they can turn out to be in the long
run far less consequential than we
originally imagined other issues receive
less contemporary attention and they
turn out to have far more important
long-term consequences when through
through a historical lens now the
standard probably most of us use media
coverage is of course absolutely the
wrong one right there's a few things I
know but the one thing I know when I do
my first reading of history is that New
York Times always gets it wrong all
right and if the New York Times gets it
wrong you can only imagine what the
media writ large gets wrong and this is
the idea of figuring out in real time in
contemporary time what will matter in
the long run and the media is very bad
at doing that but I'm going to use an
example from the past it's very
controversial to kind of highlight that
and that's the Vietnam War now the
Vietnam War if you pick up any textbook
on 20th century American history any
book on the 1960s any book on u.s.
foreign policy any discussion among
policy makers of a certain age in
Washington and the Vietnam War is of
course of central defining importance it
was a brutal
too many Minds misguided conflict took
thousands tens of thousands of American
lives debilitated the US economy and
left a bitter political and cultural
legacy that permanently affected
American institutions but I would ask
looking back from the current
perspective was the Vietnam War as
important was it the only international
policy issue great significance that was
going on at that time was the war in
Southeast Asia in fact the most
important long-term u.s. pourraient
foreign policy question of the day if
you picked up the New York Times at the
time of course it was but if you thought
historically and thought in terms of
chronological proportionality would it
be that way
I've already highlighted to you what I
think the consequences and legacy of the
1967 six-day war had for US policy in
the Middle East there's no denying that
what US policy in the Middle East right
now is at the forefront the most
important thing that most foreign policy
people are thinking about particularly
if you expand it to the greater Middle
East and I would argue the 1967 war was
perhaps the key event in shaping the
policy's environment that we face today
nuclear proliferation treaty 1968 I
alluded to some of it's odd and unusual
origins if you were to pull most foreign
policy experts today and say what is the
most important global policy facing
issue facing the United States it would
be nuclear proliferation the Obama
administration has made it their
priority their absolute assent their
foremost thing that they want as part of
their legacy to be the question of
nuclear proliferation the nuclear
proliferation treaty was negotiated and
signed during this period if you pick up
a New York Times during that period you
might see a mention on b3 or something
of the negotiations but it's dwarfed by
any mention of the Vietnam War wasn't
completely ignored but it was certainly
not given anywhere near the attention of
the Vietnam War longer-term developments
such as the emerging stability in date
on Central Europe which starts to take
root in the 1960s or the evolving fall
between the United States and
China which is perhaps one of the most
important geopolitical events of our
lifetime begin in the 1960s these had
extraordinary long-term consequences for
world politics but lacking a singular
event or crisis these tectonic shifts in
world politics were often under played
and in China's case at least until
Nixon's Nixon's visit to China 1972 now
I'm being purposely controversial here
this is not to diminish the historical
importance the Vietnam War or even in
our own times the war in Iraq and
Afghanistan it's merely to point out
that such events can crowd out the focus
on other less noisy developments that
may have equal or even greater long-term
consequences I think it's fair to say
that there's a lot of other things going
on in the world right now the 30 years
from now will make us wonder why we were
thinking about Afghanistan so much any
number of issues and they will see the
same thing happen they're developing the
historians skill of chronological
proportionality can help a policymakers
see the bigger picture the rise of China
shifting demographic trends changes in
the sources of energy supply may turn
out to have an equal even greater
long-term consequence for us global
policy than Iraq or the Afghan war even
if they do not dominate the front page
of the newspaper in the same way that
each of these wars do the fourth concept
unintended consequences history is also
good at exposing the ironies dilemmas
and unintended consequences of policy
consider again the consequences of the
Vietnam War what would have happened if
the United States had quote unquote won
the Vietnam War what if we play the
counterfactual of a u.s. victory in
Southeast Asia and see if we can play
out what history might have looked like
and whether it would have been a good
thing or not one plausible scenario is
not it's not hard to imagine that you
would have had a United States bogged
down in South Vietnam drained keeping
its military resources and economic
resources pouring into Southeast Asia
forever pouring in blood and treasure to
support a weak state surrounded by
enemies if the United States had one in
Vietnam China and Russia may have
subsumed their mutual enmity to the
larger goal of reducing American power
in Asia
remember the Russians and the Chinese
hated each other but that hatred did not
really emerge until it was clear that
the US was leaving Southeast Asia if we
had stayed the Chinese and Russians
would have had all the more reason to
cooperate with each other
it is certainly hard to imagine the
risks between a Vietnam and China which
emerged after we left flowering in an
open conflict the United States had won
the war but the United States of course
did lose the war in Southeast Asia and
it did bring its forces home the
military defeat of the United States
though terrible you know a terrible you
militant humiliating dragon American
power and reputation assured in a period
of intense reassessment within many
institutions particularly the military
which arguably had greater long-term
consequences for American military power
you talked to anyone in the US military
of a certain age and of a certain rank
and they talked about the signal
experience of the Vietnam War and how
that shaped and changed the way they
view the institution and how the US
military went through extraordinarily
dramatic reforms which may not have ever
happened in if the war in Southeast Asia
it turned out differently more
importantly of course from a
geopolitical perspective is a u.s.
withdrawal may have hastened a bitter
sino-soviet split it's not a coincidence
that as we are leaving Southeast Asia
we're becoming friends with China and as
we're leaving Southeast Asia Russia and
China develop more and more bitter
hatred for each other
perhaps the biggest surprise in all of
this is that China once they
successfully get the United States out
of Southeast Asia ends up having a war
with a unified Vietnam now from the
perspective of geopolitics a u.s. defeat
which divided the Communist world in
Asia was much better than a Vic
Dury which would have led to an
expensive long-term commitment in the
face of the unified communist front one
might also speculate that the weakened
status of the United States could have
tempted the Soviet Union to intervene
more deeply in places like Africa and
Afghanistan in ways that certainly were
of no help whatsoever to the long-term
Soviet position in the world
understanding that history is not always
linear linear and that the force of
events can a powerful and unanticipated
effects does not mean that policymakers
can be expected to understand how their
policies can produce unexpected and
indeed unwanted consequences I'm the one
who started out by saying you can't
predict the future and you shouldn't try
but manat suggests just blithely using
counterfactuals in order to try to
predict what's actually going to happen
what I am saying though is that this
kind of historical knowledge that
emphasizes that important events almost
always have unforeseen and unintended
results it should provide some humility
to the decision-maker
it should sensitize people in decisions
of great response in positions of great
responsibility to the fact that things
can and will go wrong and the only thing
that we can predict with any certainty
is that things will turn out much
differently than you would ever plan and
the whole idea here is to look beyond
disaster and defeat and paradise in
victory what's the fifth concept the
fifth concept is to develop the skill to
recognize when policy is insignificant
this is probably the hardest one for
policy maker this is what policy makers
do right you and I teach it US policy
school and you ask policy students how
does the world work well you know I
joined an NGO I get into government and
we shift and change the world that's how
things work right 90% of the world is
driven by the policy-making process the
rest of it you know is sort of kind of
all fluff well that's not how the world
works right a familiarity with good
historical work can help government
officials and people and other
organizations understand that when
they're making an implementing policy
policy is nowhere near
as important as they are accustomed to
thinking in other words history can
provide policy makers or decision makers
with the confidence to do nothing right
this is one of them so the skill we
would love people in Washington in lots
of other places to have do nothing this
is true even when events are the
historical processes that influence has
true even when events and historical
processes influence or even shaped the
policy environment reflect upon the
global position of the United States in
the mid 1970s I want to give you sort of
a story that as Californians you're all
going to be very familiar with a very
proud of but I think highlights what I'm
trying to get at again the u.s. 1975 how
do things look not very good we just
lost a war
we'd had a president resign a disgrace
the economy is suffering greatly there's
a sense of political and cultural
malaise was there anything in 1975 that
would have led anyone to predict that
the United States was about to begin an
extraordinary three decade plus economic
and technological surge the likes of
which the world had never seen before in
retrospect this post Vietnam era which
at the time anyone in any position of
power any commentator talked about as
the decline of the United States
actually were the seeds the roots of a
great American rebirth and a great sort
of Renaissance in American power it was
actually the birth date of our current
age of power trickle triggered by
globalization led economic growth and
there's three fun California events that
I use to sort of highlight how no one
could have seen this coming and there's
somewhat antidotal all right but it's to
show
I mean if national policy makers care
about power and we live in an age where
power is the tool you use and if these
are the things that led to you having
power and policy had nothing to do with
it
that should be an important lesson now
consider these three events the first
obviously the creation of the first
Apple Computer in 1970
six signaling the dawn of the high-tech
age dominated by Silicon Valley and a
revolution in telecommunications and
information technology who in Washington
saw that coming
anyone the second event the release of
the 1970 in 77 of the movie star wars
the highest-grossing movie of all time
highlighting the increased dominance of
US popular culture that would spread
around the globe like wildflower people
are probably familiar with Joe NIH's
notion of soft power the idea that your
culture and your ideas and your beliefs
are an incredibly important instrument
in spreading your national interests
well how does that manifest itself
coca-cola Levi's jeans Star Wars right
this is the signal that American culture
which one could have imagined would be
in a period of decline this is the
beginning when we see American culture
actually stepping up and increasing its
influence around the world and the third
is always my favorite and this sort of
drives my policymaker friends nuts and
that's the Stags the famous Stag's Leap
victory over Paris wines because the one
complaint you get around the world
globalization it's this American it's
that sort of dumbing down of everything
lowest common denominator
yet here it's just a certain extent from
a historical perspective the story of
Napa Valley is almost more interesting
than the story of Silicon Valley all
right I mean here is something that you
know in the 1950s nothing's happening
and by 1976 this event signals this
ability of high-end value-added American
ingenuity to trump anyone in the world
right it's not just making sloppy films
the French country can't just turn
around a lot Saul star wars we make
better wine than you do right we figured
something out all three of these stories
are antidotal obviously and alone
explain little but confine they give you
a sense of the tectonic shifts in
American culture its politics and in
particular its economy that would
reshape forever the global landscape and
create the world
we live in today and create the policy
environment the policymakers have to
deal with now there's no way of knowing
of course how the trends represented by
these three interrelated events would
have transformed the international order
I'm sure nobody at Apple Computer or
George Lucas or anyone in napa valley
was thinking all right this is you know
this is how we're gonna win the Cold War
but these stories serve as important
reminders to policymakers that many of
the events that leave them have the most
effect on the policy environment are not
always the direct result of policy
decisions no one in Washington had much
to do with the making of Star Wars the
first Apple Computer or the fine wines
of Northern California nor did these
events have much to do with foreign
policy narrowly defined all three
however had enormous consequences for
America's power and role in the world
for decades to come
so by emphasizing factors outside of
policy things like culture demographics
economic trends innovation social
changes historians are more aware of
these forces in understanding this
history and understanding how this
shapes the world we live in can
sensitize policymakers to the large
complex and uncertain world outside of
government decision-making scholars and
government officials often focus on
narrow definitions of foreign policy and
those that do that we're operating in
the 1970s thought they lived in an era
of decline and malaise but we look back
now and we see this is the seeds and the
origins of something very very important
and what a policymaker who's sensitized
to these ideas should be able to do is
to recognize the world they operate in
today had its seed in the supposed
malaise and it shows you that all
history happens in all sorts of strange
ways and comes from all sorts of strange
places many of them we can't control and
it should also act as a caution to
pundits or policymakers who claim to
identify an overarching trend in the
world we live in today who were make
hard and fast assessments about
America's global position the this slide
should make you anytime you hear anyone
2010 tell you anything about where
America's power is going you should just
shut your ears or laugh because there is
no one in 1976 and 1977 who thought
anything but the United States was in a
period of decline I'm actually working
on a paper right now with someone called
that 70 show which is the look is the
United States now like the u.s. in the
1970s or is it like Great Britain in the
1870s in the 1870s in Great Britain the
United State had everything going for it
leading technology great military power
incredible education system and that
decade was the beginning of their long
slow and painful decline to conclude
it's natural to think of events
unfolding and transparent linear fashion
and it's no surprise that we desire
crisp parsimonious explanations of the
most important issues we face mixing the
element of intense time pressure and
it's easy to see why most policy makers
don't or can't embrace the complexities
uncertainties and ambiguities that mark
historical explanation and the payoff
requiring such skills is not all we've
always readily apparent a familiarity
with good historical scholarship will
not necessarily help government
officials make specific policies on a
day to day basis I don't know what this
lecture would necessarily tell a person
about how they should conduct policy in
Afghanistan I might have opinions like
anyone else but that's not really what
this these sets of skills are our aim to
do to provide specific advice normal
historical analysis provide an
overarching framework or theory in which
to view or understand the world I know
people like this this is natural to have
this and historians this is not what we
provide acquiring these historical
skills will however provide other
important benefits these five concepts
discussed above will allow the
policymaker to identify patterns and
trends that shape the policy environment
it may allow him or her to recognize and
go beyond the surface level picture of
an event to access a deeper logic
living things underneath the surface
historical analysis will provide a more
finely tuned sense of the consequences
both of events and of policy responses
in the end understanding these five
concepts should make for more deliberate
thoughtful and hopefully more successful
u.s. foreign policy and there are no
reasons policymakers and diplomats from
other countries cannot benefit from
applying these rules and methods as well
historians would also benefit from
considering the concerns and interest of
the policy world keeping this important
audience in mind
intelligent government professionals who
are often overwhelmed by the complexity
and difficulty of the policy choices
they face and terrified are the
consequences if they make a mistake if
these people were kept in mind while we
were researching writing about the past
I believe it could only sharpen and
improve our scholarly work appreciating
the past for its own sake is an
important mantra for professional
historians I believe it I think that
history doesn't necessarily have to be
useful doesn't necessarily have to have
a utility for it to be important for it
to make you wiser to make you understand
the world more however this value does
not have to be sacrificed and in fact
should not be sacrificed in order to
write in a style and on subjects that
will engage and educate the policy world
like the workings of history itself the
benefits of a relationship between
historians and policy makers are not
obvious particularly at first glance the
deeper one looks
however the clearer it is that they
share important interests and concerns
and they are far far better off with
each other than without each other thank
you
let's sit over here great what are what
are some classic misuses of history
Vietnam you know every national policy
meeting I've been around the the
discussion is sort of well this is
Vietnam hers this man on the moon it's a
great question and history provides a
real dilemma in that we actually all
think historically it's just a natural
thing to do and Ernie May once said look
the reason we have to Train policymakers
is it's a lot like sex education for
teenagers they're going to do it they
might as well enjoy it and do it better
and do it safer and but that doesn't
actually guarantee you're going to get
it right so I would say one of the
biggest problems that people make is
falsely making false analogies from the
past this is something that came up in
2002 again and again about the war in
Iraq comparing a dictator to Hitler the
idea that you would compare sodomist
saying to Hitler that you should never
appease and there's certain lessons of
history in fact sometimes it's almost
more scary when people use history
poorly than when if they don't use it at
all
and we've seen plenty of examples of
that and and just to give one other
example one of the things that got me
interested in the nuclear proliferation
question was lots of my friends in the
policy world in 2001 2002 we're
comparing it's talking about this whole
rogue state phenomenon how you couldn't
allow someone like Sodom saying that
nuclear weapons I would prefer to live
in a world where there weren't nuclear
weapons and particularly where Sodom was
saying didn't have them but as I did my
historical work I looked at the US
responses to China's nuclearization in
1964 you want to talk about a rogue
regime mouth' China I mean the kind of
statements he made he made statements
saying we can fight a war with the
United States lose 300 million people
we'll still have 300 million
so we'll still win he had 25 million of
his own citizens had died during the the
Great Leap Forward he had fought India a
few years earlier at fought the United
States there was ever a state to worry
about being irresponsible about having
nuclear weapons it was China 1964 eight
years later they're our ally and that
doesn't mean that that would necessarily
happen again but it was a the kind of
understanding of the past that should
have and it was recent past should have
given people when they think about Iraq
or Iran some pause well it gives me
pause as my contemporaries in 1964 we're
quoting my approvingly revolution is not
a tea party power comes out of the
barrel of a gun
barefoot doctors and yeah whoa funny
we're not doing that for the Iran that
somehow that that's a model of how the
left should behave question from praveen
said the media often gets it wrong I
think you said me the applause gets it
wrong why do you think that happens and
what should media organizations do
differently or bloggers for that matter
it's a very good question
one of the and one of the real benefits
of history is they're providing a
perspective but what I am actually
advocating is to try to do more
contemporary history so it's a little
bit tough because journalists are going
to respond to the events of the day and
they're going to have to do it in real
time and they're gonna have a very
difficult time measuring and weighing
what's important and so that's the first
then that's that's the excusable part as
a historian I would probably make the
same mistakes but at least knowing
something about the past would have
given me a sense that you know in 1994
maybe the what's happening with OJ
Simpson isn't the most important thing
in the world no one will talk about a
five years later and I wouldn't you sort
of have a blaring coverage on CNN or the
New York Times one of the signs for an
editor that this is something might have
long-term consequence and we should
maybe play it up because with any
our times and we do that you know it's a
good question we're very events oriented
and so some of the things that are most
important and I had to say I there is
some encouragement of this you look at
the reaction and the press is coverage
on global climate change and it actually
is it's a sign that there is hope here
is something that there's not a singular
event it's a process develops over time
it's technical it's hard to understand
it's hard to grasp it's a bunch of
eggheads talking about it which in
America that always guarantees death for
any sort of story and yet it's had some
resonance and it would be interesting to
actually study why that is because you
would actually predict that no one would
actually cover that this the second
reason though in addition to not having
perspective is these things are market
driven right people want why do people
look at accidents on the road they know
they shouldn't but that's what they want
and you know the media is only a
reflection I mean if tomorrow everybody
wanted to go out and watch people recite
Aristotle on television then that's what
CNN would do right it's not CNN pushing
this down anybody's throat but so part
of it is developing our own sense of
what is important and what's not
important well you mentioned climate
change what are the historical
precedents for climate change and you
know are historians any use in this
discussion yeah one of the things that's
really challenging is that and I would
actually have added this as a sixth
skill is that there are times where the
past actually doesn't provide us with a
lot of good lessons and that's actually
a good thing to know if you can look in
the past the most interesting thing of
course about climate change from a
foreign policy perspective is that these
solutions it's a problem of the it's a
sort of a public goods global Commons
problems if solution is going to
necessarily have to be transnational the
sort of the way most historians of
international relations think they think
about states being actors they think
about relative gains and that doesn't
work here so there aren't a lot of
really good models there's some in
international economics in terms of the
idea
that there is a place where if we all
cooperate we all benefit but even if
there isn't a precedent for climate
change recognising that understanding
that's important because though we
oftentimes make claims of things being
novel and more often than not they're
wrong but if you can actually go back
and say I've looked at this this is a
unique problem it is novel then that
opens up the possibility to think
differently and off the top of my head
there aren't a lot of historical
precedents that provide us macro
guidance for how to deal with climate
change but that's okay because that will
help spur innovation to think all right
now it's fine to think about new ideas
Kevin Kelly yes do you have any examples
of a leader or a group that has used
history and the way you recommend it
well you've been around some
policymaking I think yeah did they
listen were you glad they did stuff like
that I would what you see is that
certain leaders are more understand more
that they're under that they have a
historical legacy they have to worry
about and that their decisions are gonna
matter what's the dynamic of that what
is that it's the way they actually seem
to think larger than the immediate day
and then that there's this legacy thing
and so they're concerned not about
president historians talking about the
past that they are concerned about
future stories talking about them well
they've even goes beyond that I'll give
you a perfect example one of my
President Kennedy during the Cuban
Missile Crisis and I have an
interpretation the Cuban Missile Crisis
it's a little different than most people
normally assume that Kennedy gets
together these smart people in a room
for 13 days and they discuss and debate
what the best solutions are and they
come out with the best ideas I actually
think he put those 13 people in a room
so he could keep them they're not
causing problems and then he actually
went out with his brother and they
pursued a informal line of diplomacy
with the Soviets because their advisers
were saying you need to be hawkish you
need to be hard you need to do things
that this is this is all if you if you
this is your gonna be like Neville
Chamberlain and Kennedy had an instinct
that wasn't right he had an instinct
that he would have a really hard time
explaining to the world if there was a
world that he had pursued policies that
had led to the deaths of tens of not
hundreds of millions of people the
Khrushchev think the same way do you
think he did he did Khrushchev is one of
the most fascinating irresponsible sort
of political leaders ever he knew he got
himself in trouble and Kennedy through
his knowledge of history understood that
the last thing you do with an enemy is
push him in a corner so they can't get
out
and so they pursued a whole completely
different line of diplomacy in fact Dean
Acheson figured this out and no one's
ever really talked about this Dean
Acheson was very hawkish you can't back
down and Acheson said I'm not going any
more of these meetings because it's
clear this isn't why our policies being
made Kennedy kept these people locked in
the White House so that he could then go
and make the policies that got him got
the resolution the Cuban Missile Crisis
such that it ended in a way that was
beneficial to the United States and
didn't lead to a nuclear war and many of
the things that were being discussed in
that room were not were things we
especially now know that things were a
little scarier than we even would have
imagined if we had had an airstrike we'd
had a land invasion there were tactical
nuclear weapons that may have been under
control the Cubans who wanted to use
these things and who knows what would
have happened and Kennedy had this sense
and it's I think a larger historical
sense that he had a responsibility and
duty to think beyond the moment he lived
and to think sort of in a larger sense
what is this going to look like twenty
or thirty years not just for historians
but when you're dealing with nuclear
weapons as to what the consequences of
your actions might be so he dialed it
back and instead all we did was kind of
embargo and and stop a ship but not
shoot it down and stuff like that are
some examples that you have of
policymakers brilliantly doing nothing
brilliantly doing nothing is probably
the hardest thing in the world because
you don't get any credit for brilliantly
doing nothing let's see if the Obama but
if we listen to historians and that
would become a new category right and
you know some leaders would be so proud
i brilliantly did not
for the first three years of my
administration there's clearly I need to
improve the sort of political spin
aspects of those recommendations because
running on a platform of I will do
nothing for four years thinking the last
couple of elections if someone had
actually run on that hey pretty good
right I would say and there's a very big
split in the administration about this
but in terms of policy towards Iran if
they end up doing nothing which I hope
they end up doing nothing and I think
that there's a lot of people in the
administration who hope they end up
doing nothing but it's it's going to
require very careful balancing of a
whole number of situations if they end
up pulling that off that'll be an
example of wise recognition that doing
nothing is sometimes better than doing
something my sense of that discussion
within the administration and maybe to
some extent the previous administration
is that the military are kind of on the
side of let's do nothing here our plate
is full and these guys are weird people
we don't want to deal with just now
thank you
and but the elected officials who are
sort of telling the national story of
the times of counterterrorism all the
rest of us and all my dear that you know
the nuclear power is the scariest thing
out there that they are you know that
doing nothing looks bad from their stand
book so how does the discussion like
that play on relates to a question I got
from I think it's Eric does the military
do a better job of using it using an
historical perspective in developing
their policies and practices well I I
think I just thought of another example
that relates to this and this is the
Johnson administration's response to
China's nuclearization which actually I
think will tie back nicely into this
Iran example we don't typically think of
the Johnson administration as being
particularly wise when it comes to
foreign policy there was a recent poll
that and I work at the LBJ School and so
there's lots of people who care about
Johnson's reputation in the presidential
polls that come out every five years the
Secretary of State Dean Rusk Dean Rusk
said Johnson was the worst foreign
policy president of any which strikes me
is a little over the top but the the
reaction to the China situation is
interesting so here you have this state
that has been extraordinarily
threatening irresponsible threatens your
interest you fought against them you
have nuclear weapons you have a lot of
people in the administration in fact the
Kennedy President Kennedy wanted to
preemptively attack China's nuclear
facilities in 1963 and actually
approached the Soviets and said would
you be ok if we did this
he sent Averell Harriman over on a
secret mission in the summer of 1963 the
Soviets said no she's news to me as it
was to you guys yeah well it's it's very
well documented Kennedy thought that
once China had nuclear weapons they'd be
intolerable and it's ironic because the
Soviets came to the Americans in 1969
and said do you mind if we bomb China
and Nixon and Kissinger said don't do it
and actually use that as a way to go and
talk to the Chinese and say look we
should start talking they've got
problems here again two examples of
doing nothing that really worked out
nicely and in 64 Johnson put together
this blue-ribbon Commission led by Ross
well Kilpatrick hoopin McNamara's deputy
and was down in the private sector and
they looked at what should the response
be and they looked at a range of
scenarios on the one hand they called it
option 1 which was don't let anyone have
nuclear weapons prevent anyone from
having it used military force is
necessary even against the French that
was talking about what sabotage the
French nuclear force on the one hand all
the way on the other hand to say let
anyone have them we can't do anything
about it and they came down in the
middle let God sort him out yeah I hear
that one but the one thing they did
decide that was very smart was let's not
make a big deal about it if we're on the
front page in the newspaper every day
saying China can have a bomb China can
have a bomb China's they're saying then
we were gonna think about getting a bomb
they're paying attention to this right I
mean you see this actually in the
documents on some of the captured
al-qaeda documents where they say
everyone in the West is talking about
these chemical weapons we had a look
into that right and that's an example of
with China the decision was made not to
overreact in fact it was downplayed it
was ignored it was there were people
saying let's deploy a missile defense
system let's attack it let's sort of
create a sort of a kind of some sort of
new deterrent posture that's threatening
to China they did none of that and it
turned out to be wise and that's an
example of you know if with Iran if we
said you know if you want to build these
things you know good luck with that it'd
be interesting to see how that would
change the political calculus in Tehran
now you've said that a number of nations
either had were headed toward nuclear
having nuclear weapons and then backed
off who are they and why did they back
off well in the 1970s there were
probably anywhere between 15 and 25
nuclear weapons programs some really
surprising countries Australia had a
super-secret nuclear weapons program
that you didn't know that
Yugoslavia Brazil Argentina South Korea
Taiwan South Korea and Taiwan and over
time about three or four times started
to develop their weapons program and
each time we came and said stop that cut
that out
I mean after Nixon went to mainland
China Taiwan was obviously concerned and
they said we've got to do something for
our own security South Korea in the late
70s when the Carter Administration
talked about pulling troops out South
Koreans said well we're gonna be on our
own here we need nuclear weapons and
each of the cases were different but
there's a variety of arguments there's
one argument that the US and many of
these cases came in and said law will
protect you South Korea tawan West
Germany Australia will protect you in
other cases particularly a country like
Brazil or Argentina there seems have
been an internal discussion where people
said what do these really get us we
could why not open our economy and
globalize you look at Brazil is a great
example this now it's got this dynamic
economy that's growing it's developing
leadership in all sorts of ways
and there's skewed nuclear weapons and
their argument is and I think there's a
compelling argument that the countries
that develop them they really didn't get
them very much so there's a variety of
reasons if this story has turned out to
be far more successful than we ever
would have thought or predicted and I've
heard I have heard a theory from some
military guys that outside the military
establishment had been in that frame of
reference who think that mutually
assured destruction really worked that
the great powers did not fight each
other because of mad and if nuclear
weapons went away and all we could fight
with is you know big tank battles and
drones and whatnot that the great powers
would go operably go back to war with
one another what's wrong with that logic
historically I think it's fundamentally
misleading to think that people
necessarily go to war because of the
weapons they have what they States don't
decide one day you know we have the
first strike capability against Canada
we've had for quite some time
we haven't invaded Canada and the fact
is the Soviet Union in the United States
were big powers they had competing
interests those competing interests
clash they have competing ideologies
that was the sort of the source of the
friction they would have had that
friction in a non-nuclear world I would
actually argue that the nuclear weapons
actually increased that friction because
it increased the sense of uncertainty it
heightened the risk it made everything
more dangerous I actually don't think
and this is I've changed my mind on this
five years ago I would have agreed with
those military people and looking up I
think nuclear weapons throughout the
Cold War where hindrance not a help to
stability and a lot of people who
trained me would be horrified to hear me
say that but it's I've spent a lot of
time recently looking at the Berlin
crisis and I played a counterfactual
what would have happened in non-nuclear
world over Berlin crisis what would
happen is we would have given up our
Lynn right because we've been defended
it was 100 miles in East Germany we're
I'm gonna go to war over that in fact
Eisenhower says over and over again how
in the hell do we get to defend these
indefensible things these crazy little
islands off Taiwan or Berlin they're
indefensible yet because we had nuclear
superiority we thought we could do it
and the Soviets who said we care about
Berlin more than you do you couldn't
possibly think you're going to defend
this and there was a great amount of
misunderstanding for four years that
almost led to war in a non-nuclear world
Soviets what I said we have a lot more
tanks than you do and we said you know
what you're right you hug you get Berlin
and that might not be that might not be
that might not be the ideal outcome but
it's certainly the the opportunities for
war misunderstanding certainly would
have would have been far less I played
the same counterfactual of what would
the Cold War look like without the
Berlin crisis and the same sort of thing
Berlin and it's unusual position was
such a irritant that that one problem
explains maybe 40% of the tension during
the Cold War and if that had been
resolved if there hadn't been a billion
issue I think the Cold War would have
been much different
well it's interesting I happened it I
was in the Army at the time the wall
went up and was sent over to
photographic cassette so I was doing at
the Pentagon then and it was a pretty
weird artifact yeah slashing across the
city and across the German landscape and
the Cold War was deemed over when that
wall came down so the specificity of
that seemed to help people sort of say
okay there was a Cold War and then there
was in 1989 wall came down and we're
done now
right does it help they have that kind
of kind of event specificity if you did
two historic history does seem to have
something like heroes these tectonic
shifts tectonic shifts are usually
happened by earthquakes and that seemed
to be one of them so have you gained by
having that specificity so I it can be
as helpful as it can be misleading I
would say that putting up on the wall in
the 1961 you could argue that that was
almost the end of the most dangerous
period of the Cold War because that was
the elegant solution to a problem the
Soviets were facing instability the wall
and the Americans actually realized this
the crisis lingers for
little bit longer for about a year but
essentially the Soviets are saying this
is ours
that's yours we're gonna deal with this
massive outflow of refugees that's
destabilizing the regime in this
particular way and there's it takes a
little while for people to figure it out
but in some ways in ways that aren't
necessarily that appealing right because
two million people are trapped in this
horrendous situation but it removed the
great irritation and it's not a
coincidence that the most dangerous
parts of the Cold War had to do with
before the Berlin wall went down or went
up now the Berlin Wall coming down is my
story about the 1970s show I sometimes
wonder about these you know what's more
important you know the development of
the Intel microprocessor or the Berlin
Wall coming down that's the kind of
things historians had to wrestle with
how are they related did one have to do
with the other you're right people get
these images in their mind and they're
very important signposts but they can
often be misleading now there was a
policy thing that happened at the end of
the Cold War which was the it was the
Bush administration then and they
elected not to gloat not even declare
victory not to do a victory dance not to
encourage the media to do a victory
dance but just quietly let that thing
pass how did they know to do that I
think and this again shows why we have
to do a better job of selling history to
a general public as we saw how the Bush
administration was rewarded by being
voted out of office but they did show
very calm wise patient management of the
situation few people and it it does
there were a lot of things up in the air
a few people remember this but at the
time the British in the French were very
much against German unification Margaret
Thatcher worked very very hard to
undermine it in whatever way that she
could and told the Americans I don't
want to see this happen and worked on
meter-long and Bush there were a lot of
people at the time saying why you know
you can have a sort of a divided Germany
just look a little different and the
Bush administration made a very wise
choice to push forward and wasn't
inevitable that they would do it that is
an administer
again it's just one of the dilemmas of
American politics the people that were
in that administration or some of the
wisest most thoughtful historically
trained I just had dinner
Oracle II drained those fills elico I
don't know if you know Phil at all he's
a just an amazing historian and a
policymaker and who wrote the signal
book on this issue was one of the key
people making policy at the time now
again the politics of it didn't play
well at all dancing on the berlin wall
would have probably guaranteed
reelection in 1992 but that's one of the
again one of the terrible ironies of
history and policy grid garb has a
question must we wait a decade or two to
understand the historical implications
of an event or policy decision what
could your five ways tell us now about
the impact was a 2008 right I think for
that matter the policymakers of 2008 I'm
the main thing it can tell you is
humility that you're your first cut is
always wrong but you know law says
humility good for leaders yes
okay I think it's hard to think of the
last ten years and think of little
humility wouldn't have been somewhat
helpful and by humility it's not just
personal humility it's the idea that
using policy to intervene and
complicated affairs that we can send the
how decide all right here's a state they
have a certain way of living we're gonna
intervene in a certain way we're gonna
transform the way that we're living any
even kind of a slight interaction with
history would tell you that that's
that's a problematic notion right that's
not how the world works and I think that
I can't say that these five skills are
gonna tell you what the consequences of
2008 are we were talking earlier about
Neil Ferguson and I think he thinks 2008
is the beginning of gloom and doom I
actually more of an optimist at a
tendency to think that just like the US
and the 70s that this is a period
especially in the kind of things that
the world you live in the technological
world where it strikes me amazing things
are going on we're a very innovative
we're doing a lot better than a lot of
other people there are problems or
issues as things that need to be fixed
but my gut instinct would tell me that
the trends look good but I could be
completely wrong all right because if I
were making these predictions in the
1970s it would have been much different
but knowing that the odds are that I'm
wrong
tempers what kind of policy
recommendations that I would make a
while back you said you changed your
mind about something that was nuclear
policy and is that punished or rewarded
in your profession I had a wonderful
dissertation adviser Mark Trachtenberg
he said what you want to do is go in an
archive with an idea of how something
works and then be proven wrong because
that's what makes it fun you go in and
you say you also need a hypothesis going
in for that to happen no not necessarily
but but a lot of policy oriented social
science selects evidence to confirm
previously held beliefs in to be honest
historians do this as well but if you if
you keep in mind that the goal that it
actually could be more fun to be proven
wrong because that's surprised that's
the curiosity that gets us looking at
these things we thought the world worked
in one way and then we studied it and
learned it worked in a completely
different way who wouldn't like that
that's exciting that's fun and so when
you do when you're trained correctly as
a historian you expect to be wrong I've
just sort of in the middle of finishing
a book that's been very frustrating
because every chapter I write which is a
separate essay I end up with more
questions than I had before which
informs the next essay and the next one
and a certain point it has to stop
right and book publishers say well what
are your conclusions well you know I've
got some ideas and they want you and
what are the three things they dare to
come out and say gonna sell a book I
might have to say what the three things
are but I don't know why sometimes I
mean it's it's and to be fair this is
the kind of thing that drives
policymakers nuts because that's
debilitating you have people in
decision-making positions have to make
decisions and they know they might be
wrong they have to draw a sufficient
conclusions are insufficient data every
day right exactly long and which is
another reason why I think historians
should be more sympathetic because
one of the reasons the relationship is
bad is when we write about people in
positions of power you know President
Johnson was an idiot you didn't know
what he was in you don't think any
Johnson had this this story he would
tell he said when it came to my desk the
decision every other smart person in the
government had already looked it over
and passed it on and there was a stack
of papers yes and a stack of papers no
it was never clear what the right thing
to do was that most decisions like that
and so as historians I think we could be
a little more sympathetic to those
challenges that people who have to make
decisions could if it's okay for
historians to change their mind can they
help policymakers feel that it's okay to
change their mind or to as you're
suggesting go into a policy situation
they have the luxury to do this to treat
something they're trying as a hypothesis
that might be wrong right and if it is
they are going to have a plan B
hopefully on the table right I mean if I
were in a room advising a president to
do that every one of their political
advisors would throw me out never let me
back in again and but that's what needs
to change what needs to change I mean
you when we were at that conference in
March I remember being struck because
Phil tetlock was there and the whole
notion then you know the Hedgehog with
the Isaiah Berlin the Hedgehog versus
the Fox the guy or the gal who knows one
thing and explains the whole world
through that one thing will get on TV
and have influence and he did this major
study that showed experts are wrong more
often than the general public about
predicting major things in foreign
policy but the ones who are really wrong
are the ones you see in newspapers who
are the hedgehogs who have one way of
explaining things I don't know how you
changed that says you can this
perspective train historians to be
suspicious of hedgehogs basis yes yes
historians should not be hedgehogs and
historians should root out hedgehogs are
their anti hedgehogs but it sounds like
there are some to root out there are
among historians there's Neal Neal's a
hedgehog
let me take that McNeal as a Neal Thomas
yeah he's gonna be down the story and
it's great book called this thing called
war of the world about the 20th century
we had a debate on this stage about it
and he said that's the future yeah a few
short said no things are getting better
he is a tremendous one of the best
historians out there and I would say a
less-than-stellar analyst of the
president in the future because because
why do you think he has a theory of
what's going on yeah because I think
he's a fox when he's a historian and a
hedgehog was an analyst and he sort of
has this kind of a bipolar condition so
a policymaker a brilliant policymaker
would use Neal Ferguson's history and be
dubious about his analysis because he
could recognize these two there's
bipolar modes in him how how do you know
when you're dealing with the smart fox
versus Andover smart when you hear
someone say this is what's going to
happen in China in ten years they say
China will do X in ten years
there's no historian if you looked at
any time in the recent past when someone
said the US Russia China anyone will do
this in ten years their success rate is
remarkably bad and just even framing it
that way it's an indication that the
person is a hedgehog and you should be
very suspicious just because and again
that I mean I don't probably shouldn't
have gone on the roof of using Neal as
an example but there's more the way you
get on television the way you get in
op-ed pages is by saying this is how the
world works and from that we know these
three things will follow and people say
oh wow what a relief I thought the world
was complicated now it's all explained
to me all right and it's nice to have
people do that so what one would want
from media then being the kind of
responsible your suggestion is that they
would go back and bust the hedgehogs ten
years later or five years later or a
year later when they've been wrong yet
again right and and nail them you know
right on 60 minutes or sighting during
during this conference that you attended
one of
a really good friend of mine Matt
Connolly had suggested setting up an
organization that did that that struck
me is a little bit creepy actually but I
do think that I do think that it is
remarkable how people are not held
accountable for making these big broad
statements that turn out to be wrong I
mean I'll give it a nuclear example
again China so people one of the biggest
debates of course in Washington is what
are China's intentions is it an
aggressive state that we're gonna be a
war with them I mean you know these
debates and one way of potentially
measuring this would be looking at what
kind of military forces they build well
for the last 20 years most people the
nuclear business have predicted that the
Chinese would develop a fully robust
second strike force that look like ours
they haven't built nothing they have a
minimal deterrent it's sitting out there
if we wanted to knock it out we could
knock it out not that we would and
they've shown very little interest in
behaving the way either the Soviets of
the u.s. did with their nuclear forces
in the Cold War now I don't know why I
didn't know this didn't Betty here know
this that China doesn't have a say isn't
trying for a second strike hey there's
there's that statement of slightly worse
news well because it's I guess it was
news then they would think they were
supposed to write people when you tell
people know this hasn't happening simple
just wait well wait for what they've had
a nuclear force now from for decades
they've had it's not a money issue
right it's not a technology issue they
could do this if they wanted to they
choose not to do it they allocate their
resources elsewhere in the future they
may choose to do this or if people they
keep hearing people in Washington saying
why don't they do this and people trying
to might say geez I guess we should do
this right I talked to a a Chinese
policy maker said his great fear was
that the Chinese military would start
hearing these debates and start
realizing that wait a minute we should
be building more nuclear forces because
that's how we're expected to behave
they're really wise they'll do nothing
right right right I actually think they
have been really wise and doing nothing
I think it's the right bet and they I my
I don't know this if I had a hypothesis
it would be we have a minimal deterrent
that's enough to keep the u.s. from
invading us these things don't do very
much otherwise there's a lot of other
things we need to spend our money on but
that's the kind of Hedgehog thing that
people go on again and again the Chinese
are aggressive they're gonna build these
forces of wolf
why aren't they building these things
just wait just wait this sort of all
goes back unleashed John kai-shek's yeah
yeah service how old I am two final
questions one two softballs actually one
is what's the book you're working on
it's called blast from the past a
history and policy in the nuclear age
and it's an effort lasts from the past
last I pass I'll rise from the fast
which is my attempt to go to the
archives and look in the records and try
to really understand what was driving
thinking about nuclear weapons and how
it actually affected in shaped
international the international
environment the question you asked and
was Matt a good thing was it a bad thing
these are the kind of things I'm
wrestling with from the book do you get
a sense from that kind of thing of sort
of who was right about the reality that
was emerging who was wrong and there any
patterns in leadership matters I've
trained that in the Army now so how do
you get how do you recognize good
judgment what is going on in vice versa
you know the irony is for the hard time
I sometimes get policymakers if you if
you look in this say this particular
question there were intellectuals people
like Thomas Schelling
Albert waltz that are participating in
these debates and there are also the
ones who wrote the history of the period
you go back and look at the the records
and see a guy like Kennedy reading a
shelling paper and saying god this is
not something this isn't how policy
works there's a paper during the Berlin
crisis where shelling says we need to
show the Soviets we're tough will launch
a demonstration weapon against Kiev or
mints just to show him we mean business
all right and to the game theory crowd
this made complete sense to a guy who
actually had to get elected what does he
want me to do and so now it's the
shellings and the professor's or write
the stuff it wasn't that cool he had
this idea of signaling and all that but
it
there it one of the elements of
leadership that's important and
especially someone like Kennedy who had
actually a love of history he he he was
confident enough to realize that these
people who were supposed to be really
smart maybe didn't really necessarily
know what was the wisest thing that
there was a difference between being
smart and being wise he wasn't worried
of experts there are some of our
presidents have been steeped in history
and a lot of not is there any clear
distinction and the quality of their
administration's from that you know it's
I'd love to say well what you need to do
is to make professors presidents and
then I think the probably the smartest
presidents we've had IQ wise have been
Woodrow Wilson and Jimmy Carter and
that's not too good sort of I mean it's
like you yeah women loved history to say
Houston Wilson did a guy like I mean
Kennedy and FDR Lincoln people who had a
sensibility a historical sensibility a
sense that they were part of something
larger in a sense that things weren't
always black and white and that some you
know one of the things that's
interesting about it both FDR and
Lincoln is they would sometimes let
decisions unfold and they would only
intervene at the last minute someone
like a little soon to do that yeah yeah
someone like Wilson or younger president
bush there's a early intervention I know
what's right where there's a kind of
wisdom you know FDR and Lincoln I mean
this is the Doris Kearns Goodwin book
having lots of people that disagreed and
see how things emerge you have to have a
lot of confidence to be able to do that
and Kennedy also had that as well or
even people disagree and then you could
say all right I'm gonna make the
decision but I'm not gonna make it to
light the absolute last moment that I
have to make it to me like something
that you could write usefully on would
be what the historical sensibility means
yeah in a decision maker it's a great
city final question from Gerry Mikulski
how might we contact historians alone or
in concert to get nuanced readings of
the state of the world at present show
others as long
Gusti sorry yeah I you know there's
there are someone in the audience
tonight Daniel Sargent over there one of
the rising star historians is at
Berkeley and so Daniel do you mind if
anyone in the audience contacts you
raise your hand Daniel yeah so gather
round him and get the historical sense
abilities by osmosis in all seriousness
I think that as a professor and as a
historian I'm in an extraordinarily
privileged position where I spend my
days thinking teaching reading and
writing I live a dream life and I have
an obligation to use that knowledge that
understanding and try in whatever small
way I can to share that with other
people I don't necessarily think that's
a culture that we have in higher
education but it's one that I hope
overtime will develop and are you're
saying that right now higher education
is where people get to engage historical
thinking well my hope would be you've
got these great universities all around
here with amazing historians that it
would be a much better world if those
historians engaged in to audiences like
this instead of just writing for each
other when the questions here was we
have a Surgeon General should we have an
historian general ooh
you know there was some talk in the
Kennedy administration because Arthur
Schlesinger used to go around and follow
the president to have court historians
but the worry was they become court
historians would they be critical enough
and does getting too close corrects
problems looking in I think what we're
talking about is destroyers looking out
and being listened to as they do that
well we don't like simplicity and
generalization so yeah or rule so the
idea of having one guy or gal in charge
of it all saying this is good and this
is bad is probably not gonna work out I
mean his history and historians it's
more organic but I do think somehow or
another more needs to be done to
encourage historians to engage larger
audiences and some people do do that
right and there are these are because
history books sell very very well when
they're written for a larger audience
because people have extraordinary
examples of that that these guys could
read well
at Stanford David Kennedy writing on a
wonderful book about the Great
Depression that is he is a top-notch
first-rate historian another one at
Stanford David Holloway writing about
the Russia's nuclear program in a style
that's engaging and that's smart doesn't
sacrifice anything in terms of its
sophistication and complexity so our
historian is allowed to write about the
present from the historical framework
not if they want to get tenure I have
tenure so poor Daniel over there I start
discipline they will get tenure for
doing that right hopefully yes I mean I
look this is a whole nother conversation
I mean I have a lot of ideas about how
the university needs to be blown up and
redone and disciplines need to be blown
up and redone and how its weight around
mortal went through the room at that
yeah I I think that we're higher
education in America especially in the
humanities it's like GM 10 20 years ago
and we think everything's fine and
someone in China right now is looking at
this saying that's no way to run a
railroad and we're gonna find ourselves
20 years from now wishing that we had
thought a lot more and a lot more
seriously about this and I say this is
my colleagues and look at a forecast I
heard yeah I know I know I know I do
that as a hobby so I it's a hot okay so
if we engage historians in hobby mode
he's got me now what you're talking
about yeah it sounds cool yeah no I I
think and I'll put the historian hat
back on the modern university we live in
is a product of the late 19th early 20th
century the disciplines we have were
created from a specific historical
context and for variety of reasons they
haven't changed they've changed in the
sciences they've changed particularly in
the life sciences where some amazing
things are going on these push things
yeah yeah
but isn't a science evidently no and
although here my critique is against
humanities and social science actually
think history because it is very hard to
define as a discipline actually provides
some hope for getting around this
because historians are comfortable using
science and anthropology and economics
and whatever helps explain how things
work they have no problem it's a
grab-bag of knowledge whereas the
disciplines if you're a political
science you want scientists you want
theory if you're an economist you want
you have this certain way of viewing
things and it's very closed-minded so I
actually think history does provide part
of the solution if historians would only
wake up and realize it good luck doing
that thank you a lot thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you